[Music]
the 10 make that nine habits of very
organized yesterday on Twitter actually
I pleaded that I was appearing on your
show tonight and that you were going to
hold the book up with Magnum initi which
is a word I made up magnum initi Magnum
in it yes so whatever you think
Magnum inity might be it feels yes yeah
you defined it so clearly
[Applause]
yeah very what just happened to me no I
think there's a small stroke now how
long have you been on Twitter well I've
been on Twitter about a year and a half
and but then I realized you know all of
us have been if anybody who's kept you
do try to throw that off no I didn't
either
anybody who's ever kept a journal really
has been tweeting to themselves because
they are short little entries yes and
you know I have actually kept a journal
of all my my whole life of and I realize
I have kept a journal of my appearances
on your show really hey I made a little
records and comments of how I thought
the show went and I brought it down
tonight this is well even long before
Twitter you were making a little
comments about this is fascinating I
know isn't that fascinating it is so I
thought I would read what I thought of
how the show here's a December 8 to 2007
did Conan O'Brien show went well
io is very hot audience was good
Conan seemed sluggish
January 6 2008 did Conan O'Brien very
hot show had some great ad-libs
Conan seemed sluggish did his dog died
[Laughter]
15 2009 had dinner with Conan always
loves spending time with him to practice
fake laughing
[Applause]
I'm missing you in there let me explain
a little bit about yes you know people
go you're crazy but you know my not you
me oh all the proceeds are going to
charity for me because I include tweets
by responses because I think they're
very very funny so I just want to
explain well you have your tweets and
then some of the responses you get and
you actually you upset some people
because and I remember when you're doing
this you started tweeting you said you
were tweeting from jury duty right and
people took you at your word yeah but I
wasn't you weren't you weren't right
yeah but some very summary of funny
tweets in here this was the first one
you did work enjoyed unique defendant
looks like a murderer guilty hating for
an opening line
people really cut up they got upset yeah
here's another one right here these are
real tweets that you sent out from
Georgia next one that's just stupid
couple even X's plus they want me to
play oh and then there was another one
that caught my eye remember when this
went out
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I remembered seeing that and then you
did include a response I clue I include
with other responses from people yes
response to people this one I thought
was particularly interesting response
this is a real response that yeah I
think I'm the only person in the world
that truly understands you and gets your
humor that said you know it's a social
medium you have to include the good with
the bad
exactly things not a wonderful thing
well you know it's such as I love it
when you're on the show thank you very
much now you forgot your turtle yeah
you've got your journal I can I could
really feel when the indus comes yeah
yeah hey should i should i put in my
thoughts about tonight yeah you might as
well you've done it for every other
audience very hot
Andy delightful Conan seemed robust
that's that's not the word I'm thinking
of row row robotic
[Laughter]